i wrote something yesterday with the
comments that stefan diggs made to us
super bowl week about what the sean
watson should do at this point because
all it took was one very well-timed
tweet last year from diggs yeah to get
his trade out of minnesota and diggs
told us
he doesn't need to do anything the team
knows the team knows he doesn't have to
do anything well the problem is
the team's not acting on it and i can't
help but wonder whether or not
at some point desean watson has to go
full-on sit-down interview public
i want out i want out i want out i don't
think it's enough for his
personal quarterback coach quincy avery
to tweet after carson wentz gets traded
what's the criteria for a quarterback
asked to get traded then actually
getting traded asking for a friend
the first time the phrase asking for a
friend actually was asking for a friend
his friend is deshawn watson he can't
get traded i think the criteria is even
though carson wentz didn't have to do
this
i think for watson he's got to put
pressure on them i think one of the
reasons they let jj watt go
was because they feared jj watt putting
public pressure on them and making them
look bad
i think they need to fear that watson is
going to put public pressure on them and
make them look
worse than they already do that may be
the thing that's going to break this
this log jam because as you said they're
not picking up the phone
they're not responding to offers they're
not doing anything
i think watson's got to do something
short of holding out come july
right he's got to do something between
now and then to to
really rattle them and really call them
out and get into more detail he talked
late in the season about the culture and
the things that need to happen
i think everyone needs to hear more from
him needs to hear his voice
i want out and here is why and i think
that
would help push this toward getting a
solution
and i don't think he would come away
from it being viewed as a villain i
think a lot of people understand why he
wants out
i just think he's at the point where he
needs to say so chris i think we're
getting there too mike
i i would agree with that uh he i don't
think it's in his nature
first off right i mean we've been around
him a few times uh
he's as nice as they come they just he
he couldn't be a nicer guy he is
literally the guy that you're like
wow i wish my daughter could bring him
home right i mean and he could be
like he's he has almost just got such a
great
way about him he really does and i don't
think he wants to ruffle feathers or
make headlines
you know with bold statements and i want
to get out of here because i think also
he does like the city of houston and all
that he doesn't want to disrespect those
fans
but i think the time has come that he
might have to start saying something
you're right and applying the pressure
let it be known maybe even let it be
known a little dysfunction that you're
unhappy with
and get that out there yeah i do it is
like you said
it's much different than the what when
situation the one situation
the city didn't even i don't even know
what the philadelphia fans really wanted
i mean they didn't want wins so that
wasn't really that hard
watson is different he is definitely one
of the five six best players in the nfl
and of course the fan base down there
wants him but you're right i think the
j.j watt thing they were scared he was
kind of speaking out a little bit
towards the end of the year
he was giving all those signals and i
think it's time to sean watson if he
really wants out there and start to make
moves and get this going he probably is
gonna have to do that here soon too
it was a great item last week in the
athletic that traced
the the the core of
the the acrimony and it goes back to
last year deandre hopkins gets traded
deshaun watson finds out on social media
then
bill o'brien tells deshaw watson he's
going to be more involved
in things and then cal mcnair after
o'brien is gone he's going to be
involved in
the quarterback or the coaching search
excuse me and
just you know one after another one
promises are broken to him and then he
finds out about the casario hire that
that hard turn to the left when they had
a group of finalists
and they go hire nick casario he found
out about that on social media as well
so that's part of why he
feels the way he does and and also
another great item from that athletic
article
he chooses to be stoic in the face of
any and all adversity because he saw his
mother handle
cancer that way right so that that's
inspired him to always handle his
business in a very
even-handed calm manner and and
i i think that it would be a big deal
for him
to sit down and bear his soul about
everything
that's bothering him and and i think
that
he would like to think that you don't
have to go that far to get
what you want once you make it clear to
the team that you're not showing up so
it may have to be his actions
that do the speaking for him because
there's a chance he he's just not wired
to do what he may need to do to get a
trade before he sits out
training camp preseason if there is one
regular season
as long as dwayne brown had to stay away
before before he finally got traded in
the 2017 season to seattle chris
yeah well he the mcnair family
or the ownership there whatever they
haven't shown to be the most
compassionate group in the history of
football towards their players i mean
i'm sorry that's just the way it is it's
the way it looks i don't know what else
to say
when captain america j.j watt he starts
thinking the the
you know the organization is
dysfunctional then i mean he's another
guy i mean that's not in jj watts nature
to want to get out of a place and do
that that says it
all right there it's problems you know
sound the sound the alarms there's
something wrong there
and i think with this desean watson
thing yeah i don't i mean
they don't seem i know they want him as
the player
but i don't know do they really care
that he doesn't want to be there i don't
know the mcnair family seems a little
insensitive that way to me i'm sorry
so i think he might have to apply the
pressure to get what he wants and really
make it public
and get out there and i know it's not
within you know like we talked about
what he really wants to do but yeah you
look at this right here i mean
these this is a lot of issues that a a
franchise quarterback has had to go
through
you know jamie roots the palchick billy
o'brien deandre hopkins brian gaines
let alone all the promises like you
talked about that were broken he has
every right to not be
happy being there there is no doubt
about that let alone
we know how people feel
about the environment there and
hey let's let's be honest i i think
there's a lot of african-american
players that aren't necessarily
all that comfortable there for the
history that's gone on with that houston
texans football team
and i think he's had enough and it's
just you know at this point it's just
when are the texans gonna start fielding
calls or when is he gonna get to them to
finally just drive the nail home to go
no i'm not coming back there's no way
and you better
make a move soon or i'm gonna have to
start making this a little ugly
and i'm gonna have to start talking
about some of these stories and making
it public
and letting it go from there and i think
that's probably gonna be his only way
out of there as it looks right now
we had the list up compiled by jeff
darlington of espn
of just some of the individuals who have
left the organization
since jackie used to be arrived and
assumed a
higher title and now currently is the
executive vp
of football operations others have been
let go as well and what do we hear
constantly when it comes to these folks
who have been let go culture culture
culture culture we have a new culture
they don't fit the culture culture
you then you have a starting quarterback
that doesn't want to be part of the
culture and he's made it clear
why do you want to keep him there
if you are so determined to change the
culture
and you have a guy who says i don't want
to be part of this culture
why in the world would you keep him why
in the
world would you not give him what he
wants unless
unless and this gets back to 2017 and
the catchphrase that will haunt this
franchise for years to come right
we can't have the inmates running the
prison and this is all just a power play
to show the players
that there are limits to what they can
do and limits to what they can get
and if you want out even if it's in our
best interest to let you go
it's in our better interests to never
show
that the inmates are running the prison
and i'm concerned that's where this is
coming from
the culture that's being set there all
traces back to jackie used to be and
that's the other challenge for this team
because
i don't think his master plan included
becoming a villain
in houston to the extent that he now is
consider this tweet from charles
robinson
from over the weekend reserved for
social distancing and anyone other than
jack easterby
i mean you're not supposed to know the
name the average fan is not supposed to
know the name
jack easterby you're not supposed to
know the executive ep of football
operations has no relevance whatsoever
to the product he's become so notorious
in houston
i don't know how this is sustainable but
it's sustainable because the person
who's in charge of the team is stubborn
and is dug in and is not letting go and
is not going to let anyone
tell him how to run his business it's
that simple yeah i think that
you know and again nick casario i look
at him you know i got a lot of respect
for nick casario as you know i worked
with him up in new england he's got to
be wondering what the hell have i gotten
myself
that's what i was about to say i mean he
that that that to me is probably the
reason
you know there's a really concrete line
right now in the sand a concrete line in
the sand you know that's hard to do but
you can do it
all right but i think with that
that was a good one i like that 27
minutes that's good
we're back baby um but but i
i i think he's probably like wait i took
this job because of this guy
you know i just that's why i'm here i
thought we have this guy and i can build
around him and do that
so i'm sure he's gonna exhaust every
last avenue
and every last thing he can do to make
it work
but it just doesn't seem like there's
anything you do at this point from
everything i know
around the nfl just nothing have i heard
to just give me an inkling to think oh
desean watson he might crack
and go back to the texans i don't get
the sense of that from
anybody it is not going to happen
and i think if deshaun watson really
wants to move this along and get in the
place he wants to get
and have the trade work out the way he
wants
it to work out i would advise him to do
it and get going now
before you know too many chairs get
filled through free agency in the draft
and then you might be really stuck in a
spot where a team now is like well we
wanted you but
we made other we went to plan b it was
so long
and now we can't take you so that's
where i would go to him and
and his people around him and go i think
it's time to be
you know aggressive now and start making
moves that's the risk the texans are
taking and they need to understand it
they understand it fine but they go from
a situation where they have maximum
leverage because they can bring
a maximum number of teams to the table
teams
for which watson would play he's got to
play ball with this because he's got the
no trade clause but five six seven teams
let's say
yeah and then you just work them against
each other and get the best possible
offer period the problem is you're right
if they wait the panther is eventually
going to say screw this
we're going to make other plans other
interested teams screw this broncos uh
we're going to make other plans dolphins
screw this we can make other plans
and then you're down to one team exactly
and you're the eagles
trying to unload carson wentz at that
point and you got one team which means
you got no leverage but now that doesn't
mean that the texans are going to get a
third round pick and a second round pick
they could become a first round pick but
it does mean you're going to get a lot
less
than you would get if you would just
accept it see chris i thought
my guess is this is just a wild guess
and i based this on
cassario's comments from the press
conference introducing
david cully as head coach there were a
couple of questions posed about watson
even though they surely wish there would
have been zero but casario's answers
made me think the door is open it wasn't
that line in the sand concrete or
otherwise it was
more open-ended right what's the
deadline for doing a deal for example
caserio didn't say there's no deadline
because we're not doing a deal
he just said we're taking everything day
by day right which implies that
hey one of these days they may get an
offer that they can't refuse and
there was another question along those
lines about whether or not they're
taking a hard line and he he
never created the impression they're
taking a hard line
there's a very good chance he's just in
a box here
because people above him in the
organization are saying
you're not trading him you're not
trading right
and and and the challenge for him is to
work through easter be to get the
message to mcnair
that it's in the best interest of the
team to trade him now
and easter be may be that firewall
that casario can't penetrate to change
mcnair's mind
and that's possibly why we are where we
are well like
let me ask you this i mean do you so at
some point i would think the texans got
to look at this and go
are we really doing are we doing
ourselves a service or a disservice here
by
continuing to drag this on you know
again
we're seeing the city the city is
dragging the team and
the employees through the mud right now
i mean they they're
i mean to have that there like what
charles robinson tweeted out
reserved for anybody social resistance
except if you're jack easterby
i mean come on you know again i think
some of that stuff
may would die down if this deshawn
watson thing was handled or you get him
out of town now yeah they're going to
take
you know a lot of crap and have to deal
with it when they first trade him
and people are going to oh my gosh you
got rid of deshawn watson
and they're going to have to take you
know their blows that way but
i think after a week 10 days then at
least it's finally done and maybe you
can start moving the news cycle to
something else like hey here's our new
quarterback here this is what we're
doing
blah blah blah so how long do they want
to keep
you know dragging themselves through
this and with all the negativity and the
people always on easter be
and everything like that i think that's
a real question for them too to go along
with this
yeah i i i agree with you i just think
that
the question ultimately becomes what is
their objective here
is the objective to send a message to
anyone and everyone who may be paying
attention especially anyone
currently in the locker room and who may
be in the locker room in the future
that we can't have the inmates running
the prison if that's their goal
if that's the if that's the message if
they're willing to take a hit
now in order to underscore that part of
the culture of this team going forward
is
the employees just work here and they
don't tell us how to run the business
we say how the business is going to be
run and maybe they have some regret
for creating the impression that deshaun
watson had a seat at the table maybe
they never intended for him to think
that
so now the line in the sand
the concrete line in the sand is don't
expect to have any say in
what we do period you
or anyone else who will be on this team
in the future
that's how football here is going to go
that's the only way to make any sense of
it
otherwise it makes no sense at all and
i'm not saying it's right i'm just
trying to understand why the hell
they're being so stubborn
when it clearly is against their
interest once you accept the fact
that he's never coming back and i really
don't think they believe they know him
better than we do yeah
i really don't think they believe he's
coming back i think this is all about
posturing
for the battle that's to come when he
holds out
and doesn't relent and they ultimately
have to decide
after sufficient financial blood is shed
what they're going to do at the end of
the day they're going to have less than
what they would have if they would just
do the best deal they can between now
and the draft
last thing i'll say uh but like th th
this
this to me you you said it already
if you could get miami carolina
and denver those three right there who
really in a lot of ways are set up to
you know they're not far off those are
three teams i would look at and go
hey when we have those teams every year
we go well they didn't make the playoffs
last year well this team's a playoff
team
all three of those teams can be that
team this year i think we would
i don't know if you agree with that but
i think caroline is close i'm not going
to say they're definitely there but i
think they're close
you get to sean watson maybe they are
there you know the denver same thing
but you know their defense pretty good
we know the young receivers all those
type of things miami they almost did
make it
man those are teams that i would think
would be very hungry thirsty whatever
for deshawn watson and you get those
three bidding against each other
let alone two they have quarterbacks
there that
hey they can come to our team and at
least you know be a band-aid for a year
or do something like that
uh but that to me would be the best way
for them to optimize
totally for what they want to get for
desean watson if you got something like
that going with those three type of
teams that i feel like are
you know arrow up and watch out this
year
uh that they could really capitalize and
get the most for
the value of watson what about your
49ers
i know they're going to get in this i do
you think and do you think do you think
the texans would want garoppolo
i would think so i mean jimmy garoppolo
is a good quarterback there's no doubt
about that i i don't look at him as a
top 10
quarterback but i think he's you know
right on the outside of that for most
people in the nfl i think a lot of
people look at him you could be anywhere
from 12 to 18 for a lot of people in
football depending on who you talk to or
something like that
but i know nick casario would be a
believer in him
for sure uh the injury thing is the
thing with with jimmy garoppolo
but you know again i don't know and i'm
i'm
like swear to you on everything i have
no idea where kyle shanahan and the
49ers want to go
i do know he has tremendous respect for
jimmy garoppolo and what he does for his
football team when he is out there
and healthy but hey if deshawn watson
if they finally start shopping him
around and doing that
you know yeah i would tell my buddy kyle
i'd go hey
you're crazy if you ain't calling
houston right now let's call houston and
let's see what's going on down there
i think a lot of teams and those are the
teams that make sense to me
you know again the 49ers as we've talked
about are a team
that's ready now i mean how many more
draft picks do you need i don't you
don't you got young guys you got
everything really
their team is about a little depth and
that's about it everything's there
so that would be a team i would look at
and and i would advise my friend or john
lynch or any of them to go
go get him if he's available try to make
it happen
one of the trades proposed by peter king
in football morning in america entails
garoppolo
to houston yeah kirk cousins to san
francisco
and deshawn watson to minnesota oh my
gosh
peter don't tease me like that not on a
monday morning
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports